Hulu has put out a ton of fantastic original
movies over the last few years — so many,
in fact, that it can be hard
to know where to start. Well,
fear not: because these are the best Hulu
movies you can't watch anywhere else.
Bad Hair starts off pretty unassumingly. Directed
by Justin Simien of Dear White People fame,
the movie follows Anna, a woman who
decides to get a weave in order to
become more successful in the world
of music TV. So far, so normal, right?
But things get kinda weird after that, first
when Anna discovers that her hair is somehow
moving on its own, and then when she begins
to have some very strange dreams indeed.
Ultimately, Anna's hair grows a life of its own,
and begins to terrorize the people around her.
Although the premise may seem absurd, Bad
Hair is also a clear-eyed critique of the
way beauty is dictated by standards
that tend to be overwhelmingly white.
In getting a weave, Anna lets those
standards take control of her life;
a metaphor Simien literalizes in the text
of his film. This is Simien's first foray
into the horror genre, and one that's
more than worth 90 minutes of your time.
Rapper Tekashi 6ix9ine has left a
huge impression on popular culture,
despite his youth — so maybe that's
why 69: The Saga of Danny Hernandez
caused such a stir upon its initial release.
This documentary film explores the controversial
rapper's life story, including his rise
to prominence in the world of music,
his continued affiliation with street
gangs, and his several arrests.
Hernandez's story is just about crazy
enough to be worthy of a documentary,
although director Vikram Gandhi is limited
by the rapper's refusal to participate in or
cooperate with filming. Gandhi gets plenty of
great footage from the people who know Hernandez
best, but without speaking to the rapper
himself, it's impossible to get the fullest
possible sense of who he is. Even so, The Saga
of Danny Hernandez offers up plenty of insight
into its subject's growing fame, and what it
means for both him and the people around him.
There's a good reason why hugely successful con
men are such compelling subjects
for documentaries. In retrospect,
it seems obvious that the entire illusion they
created was built on a house of cards — which
only makes the fact that someone was able to
pull the whole thing off even more compelling.
WeWork: Or the Making and Breaking
of a $47 Billion Unicorn provides an
in-depth look at one of the biggest
corporate busts in American history.
Telling the story of the rise and fall of WeWork
and its ultra-charismatic CEO Adam Neumann,
the film chronicles the ways in which Neumann
was able to convince his employees and
investors that the company was worth
billions more than it actually was.
Thanks to a number of interviews with
a wide range of different people,
this documentary is able to articulate
precisely just how Neumann pulled one over on
everyone. Although it was criticized for
failing to examine the broader culture of
capitalism that facilitated Neumann's
scam, the documentary is nonetheless a
compelling analysis of exactly how WeWork
came to be — and why it all went so wrong.
In Boss Level, Frank Grillo plays Roy Pulver,
a former soldier who is trapped in a time loop
of the day that invariably ends with his death.
Over the course of the movie, Pulver has to
unravel the government conspiracy that played
a role in his own murder, and take down a
villainous colonel played by Mel Gibson.
"What the hell. Let's take
this to the next level."
Much of what you'll find in Boss Level is exactly
what you'll find in any standard action movie,
but the addition of the time loop element
makes all that conventional plotting feel
impressively fresh. What's more, Grillo
— usually a supporting player in these
kinds of action movies — takes on the lead role
here, and doesn't waste a second of screen time.
And sure, the movie may not be high art,
but hey, not everything needs to be.
There's no shortage of stories
about what it's like to grow up
famous. Some look at the experience as an
incredibly exciting and enviable adventure,
while others lament the loneliness of the
celeb lifestyle. But Kid 90 offers a uniquely
on-the-ground account of what it's like to grow up
on the silver screen. The movie features archival
footage taken by Soleil Moon Frye, who became
famous as TV's beloved Punky Brewster. As it
turns out, Frye carried a video camera with her
everywhere she went throughout much of the '90s,
and so managed to capture all the trials
and tribulations of young stardom.
The documentary features interviews with a number
of stars and celebs, including Frye herself,
on what it was like to grow up with a famous face
during the '90s. Between all that archival footage
and all those interviews, Kid 90 paints a
compelling portrait of a group of people
who grew up in the spotlight — and had to deal
with the consequences for the rest of their lives.
It's not often that a great actor is able to truly
embody an iconic role. In fact, the sad truth is
that sometimes a performer just isn't a good match
for a particular character. In Becoming Bond,
filmmaker Josh Greenbaum examines one very
particular era of the James Bond franchise,
in order to take a closer look at
the relationship between character
and actor. Specifically, Greenbaum
focuses on the career of George Lazenby,
the Australian actor who only portrayed Bond
in 1969's On Her Majesty's Secret Service.
"This never happened to the other fella."
The film uses re-enactments of scenes from
Lazenby's life, as well as actual footage of
interviews with the actor, to examine why he took
on the role of Bond, and why he eventually decided
to leave the role after just one film. And while
Lazenby's time as James Bond is an interesting
enough chapter in the character's on-screen
history, Becoming Bond covers far more than
that. It also flips the script by exploring
the way that the Bond character influenced
Lazenby's own life, and how it ultimately
shaped every role he took on afterwards.
Thanks to her passionate efforts to
raise awareness about climate change,
Greta Thunberg has become one of the most
famous activists in the world. Citizens
of every continent have watched her speak
at the UN, or followed her as she traveled
across the world by boat. I Am Greta,
however, offers a more intimate look at
Thunberg's efforts to convince the world that
the climate crisis is its number one problem.
The film was knocked slightly for its lack of
truly revelatory insights into Thunberg herself,
but it's clear from her public persona that
she's not really interested in hogging any
glory. Instead, she's focused on an issue that
she sees as an emergency, and the documentary
makes it clear that her mission is much more
important to her than any specific details
about her own life. Regardless of whether you
learn anything new about her or her cause, I Am
Greta should help you understand why her activism
has been so transformative for so many people.
Weirdly enough, what The Amazing Johnathan
Documentary really gets at is what it actually
means to make a documentary. The movie's director,
Ben Berman, follows the Amazing Johnathan,
a magician dying of heart disease on his final
tour. That somewhat simple setup may sound
conventional enough, but this film has a number
of twists, each of which builds upon the others,
until it becomes almost impossible to discern
what the truth being presented even is.
Part of what makes The Amazing Johnathan
Documentary work so well is that it seems
to recognize, at least in part, how foolhardy
it is to try and find the truth while you're
pointing a camera at someone. The movie
argues that truth is always illusory,
and that this is especially the case
when the subject has their own agenda.
With the tricks that it manages to pull off, The
Amazing Johnathan Documentary turns the concept
of truth on its head, and proves that magic
doesn't always have to be sleight-of-hand.
Although many of Hulu's most successful
projects are documentaries, its narrative
films have also enjoyed a great deal of
acclaim. Little Monsters, for example,
is one of the streaming service's most
popular movies, thanks in large part
to a hugely memorable performance from
Lupita Nyong'o. The movie tells the
story of a kindergarten teacher who has to
defend a group of children from an impending
zombie apocalypse. As you might imagine, things
quickly get gory, messy, and bizarrely adorable.
Obviously, there are a whole horde of zombie
movies out there, but Little Monsters manages
to put a fresh spin on many of the genre's
most well-worn tropes. As a horror-comedy,
it can take certain tonal liberties other
films can't — and makes thorough use of
this opportunity, too. Moreover, Little
Monsters serves as definitive proof that
Nyong'o is as skilled at comedy as she is at
drama, and acts as a delightful counterpoint
to her more serious horror work. All in all,
this is the kind of offbeat, enchanting movie
that doesn't often get made in Hollywood these
days; especially in the world of zombie horror.
Few things have had a bigger impact on American
culture than Barbie, and Tiny Shoulders:
Rethinking Barbie explores the part that this
iconic toy has played in an ever-changing world.
Honing in on one specific item — especially
a toy — might have restricted a lesser work
to shallowness, but Tiny Shoulders
uses this focus to deftly examine
how western standards of beauty have
changed over the last few decades.
Barbie has contributed to a number of shifts
in culture, but she's also followed them,
and often does both at the
same time. Suitably, then,
Tiny Shoulders follows Mattel as it prepares for
the doll's biggest reinvention ever. The movie
features interviews with a number of feminists,
media commentators, and even Mattel insiders,
and tackles the vital importance of Barbie's
role as a lightning rod in American culture.
The Fyre Festival may have been the
absolute peak of 2010s scammer culture,
and Fyre Fraud tells the full story in
excruciating detail. In case you didn't know,
this 2017 festival promised to be one of
the most exclusive parties of the year.
Promotional material depicted the event as one
absolutely dripping in luxury — but when the
day of the festival actually arrived,
those promises failed to materialize.
"Now, total chaos has erupted.
Fans are fleeing the Fyre Festival on
emergency flights out of the Bahamas."
By focusing on Billy McFarland, the entrepreneur
at the center of the Fyre Festival plan,
Fyre Fraud really gets to the rot at the heart of
the event. Specifically, it asks how he managed to
convince the world that he knew what he was
doing, even when he really, really didn't.
The documentary spends plenty of
time on the build-up to the festival,
but it's definitely not time
wasted, as the payoff is almost
ludicrously sweet. The Fyre Festival scandal
was broadly publicized as it happened,
but the documentary exposes the event's
horrible conditions in even closer detail.
Fyre Fraud also gets at something deeper about
the culture McFarland exploited, by suggesting
that people are most easily fooled when they're
offered something too glamorous to pass up.
When you think of Kristen Stewart, you probably
don't think of quirky rom-coms — but if Happiest
Season is any indication, maybe you ought to.
This charming movie stars Stewart as Abby and
Mackenzie Davis as Harper, a couple who
journey to Harper's family home for Christmas.
There's just one problem: Harper's straight-laced
parents don't know that their darling daughter is
a lesbian. As a result, Abby has to pretend
that they're just close friends ... even
though she's been eagerly planning to
pop the question on Christmas morning.
Happiest Season plays into a number of
tropes found in the romantic comedy genre.
This doesn't drag the film down, however — in
fact, its strong central performances breathe
new life into those old clichés. This movie
is a sweet and delightful festive diversion,
and serves a reminder that good
actors can do great work in any genre.
Pete Davidson's turn toward the dramatic may
seem like a surprise, but for the most part,
the public seems to have embraced
it. He got a whole heap of positive
attention for The King of Staten Island,
and has now earned further praise for his
supporting turn in Big Time Adolescence.
This movie follows Davidson's Zeke,
a drug-dealing college dropout who
becomes a mentor to a rule-abiding teen.
This is a classic coming-of-age story,
and certainly features a great deal of
the genre's typical conventions. Thanks to a
sharp script and a precise ear for dialogue,
however, Big Time Adolescence manages
to transcend its formula. Davidson
in particular earned praise for his
performance in the film, which is a much
more sensitive turn than what people have come
to expect from him. The entire cast shines,
though, and they're a huge part of what makes
Big Time Adolescence one of Hulu's best films.
Untouchable was one of the first documentaries
to tackle the rise and fall of Harvey Weinstein.
Although the technical filmmaking
behind the movie is imperfect,
Untouchable nonetheless earned praise
from critics, in part because of the
urgency of the story that it tells. The movie
was released in 2018, a year after bombshell
accounts of Weinstein's history of abuse began
to be published across major media platforms,
sparking the #MeToo movement. Viewers who
know those stories may not learn anything
new in Untouchable, but this doc does at least
bring them together in a much wider context.
As has become clear in the years since the
Weinstein story first broke, the now-reviled
producer was far from the only Hollywood
personality to get away with horrendous abuses
of power. Suitably, then, Untouchable examines not
just the allegations against Weinstein himself,
but also the systems that enabled him
to hold onto his power for so long.
The stories following the creation of
comic book characters are often stories
of credit — about those who get it for bringing
such iconic characters to life, and those who
are ultimately brushed to the side. In Batman
& Bill, audiences are treated to the story of
Bill Finger, an unheralded comic book writer
who played a crucial role in creating Batman.
It wasn't until after Finger's death that people
began to recognize the massive contributions he
made to the character. But this film
asks why Bob Kane instead got all the
credit for creating Batman, even though Finger
contributed the character's signature look,
his detective skills, and many of his
arch-nemeses, among other crucial details.
"They would hire ghost writers back in the
day. Bob Kane would get credit for the story,
he'd hand it in, 'here's my
Batman story,' they're like,
'Bob, you're a genius,' and that's how the
industry worked for a long, long time."
Sadly, it took years for Finger's
legacy to be fully restored, but now,
at least, the world knows that Finger
played just as important a role as Kane,
if not more so — and this movie
is one of the reasons why.
Run is a taut, sleek, well-acted thriller.
Starring Sarah Paulson as a highly protective
mother and Kiera Allen as her sick
daughter, the movie takes pains to
establish their close relationship — before
things take several increasingly dark turns.
At its heart, Run is a movie about being
imprisoned without even knowing it. It's also
about realizing the person you've spent your whole
life with isn't who they say they are. But while
these thematic elements might feel weighty, the
movie itself is surprisingly light on its feet.
Thanks to expert work from both Paulson and Allen,
these broadly drawn characters feel distinctly
human. And even as the circumstances
of Run become increasingly absurd,
the relationship between the characters keeps
the story grounded with genuine emotional stakes.
Lin-Manuel Miranda is one of the most prolific
creators working today. Thanks in part to the
success of Hamilton, he now has his hands
on a vast array of different projects,
often acting, producing, writing, directing, or
doing any combination of those things. In We Are
Freestyle Love Supreme, Miranda helps to tell the
story of a group he started in 2004, years before
anyone knew who he was. The group was dedicated
to freestyle rap, and this documentary, directed
by Andrew Fried, tells their story while paying
tribute to the artform in which they specialized.
Obviously, Miranda is an important
part of this story, but he's not
the sum total, and even those who might
be worn out by his peppy personality
will find plenty to love in We Are
Freestyle Love Supreme. After all,
freestyle rap is about creating something
beautiful in real time, and the scenes
here that highlight that sense of spontaneity
make the documentary more than worth a watch.
Although it shares a title with the famous
Dostoevsky novel, Crime + Punishment is actually
a documentary firmly rooted in the American
experience. The film follows Latino and Black
police officers in the NYPD over the course of
four years, chronicling their brush-ups against
the system and the ways in which policing is
biased toward people in their communities.
Crime + Punishment doesn't come to any easy
answers about how the NYPD can be fixed.
Instead, it simply shines a light on the everyday
corruption that's become a part of policing,
and the other systemic abuses every police
officer eventually has to deal with.
Nor is Crime + Punishment a loud, shouty
movie. Instead, it makes its points quietly
and precisely. Ultimately, though, that only
reinforces the movie's power, making it all
the more clear that the problems endemic to
policing aren't going anywhere. It's an urgent,
vital movie that gets at the humanity
of the police officers themselves,
even as it highlights the corruption of
the institution in which they operate.
Unlike many of the documentaries
on Hulu, the subject matter and
vibe of Ask Dr. Ruth is pretty easygoing. The
film chronicles the life of Dr. Ruth Westheimer,
a sex therapist who catapulted to fame
late in her life thanks to a TV show in
which she provided candid advice
to callers about their sex lives.
What makes Dr. Ruth remarkable is her utter
willingness to discuss sex in a way most Americans
do not. She's not shy at all, and her frankness
about sex has arguably helped spur a new sense
of openness towards the subject. Thanks to her
slight stature, old age, and charming accent,
Dr. Ruth has also been able to reach a whole lot
of people who may have otherwise tuned her out.
Ask Dr. Ruth is a deeply charming film, but it's
also one that encourages open conversation about
topics that might otherwise be seen as taboo.
According to Dr. Ruth herself, sex should not
be a topic we're afraid of: We should be
willing to dive in head first, she says, no
matter what may come of it. And this documentary
embodies that stance with open-hearted abandon.
Palm Springs debuted fairly early on
in the American COVID-19 lockdown,
and it couldn't have been more perfectly timed.
The comedy, which stars Andy Samberg and Cristin
Milioti, follows Milioti's character as she
becomes embroiled in a time loop that Samberg's
character has been stuck in for some time.
"It's one of those infinite time loop
situations you might have heard about."
"That I might have heard about?"
"Yeah."
The movie has plenty of fun with that conceit,
but it also updates the Groundhog Day formula
by asking what would happen to a relationship in
which both people are forced to relive the same
day over and over again. Thanks to note-perfect
performances from Samberg and Milioti,
plus a little help from J.K. Simmons, Palm
Springs is always charming and frequently
moving. As one of the very best movies that
Hulu has to offer, it delivers not just laughs,
but genuine emotion — and a
beautiful love story, to boot.
With the advent of influencer culture, the
world has been treated to an entirely new
type of celebrity, and for some
young people, the possibilities
that the influencer lifestyle offers is
tantalizing. Jawline follows Austyn Tester,
a teenager from Tennessee trying to make it big
online so he can escape his small-town life.
Although there are plenty of movies out
there about the horrors of the internet,
Jawline is not one of them. Instead, it's a
tender look at one kid who's trying to make it,
and a subculture that has a tendency to consume
people like him and spit them out without ever
acknowledging their humanity. Jawline
doesn't pass any judgment on its subject,
instead arguing that the idea of internet fame
is so attractive because it offers a route
out of the dead-end — something that seems
increasingly hard to find in today's world.
Sometimes, documentaries choose
to tell stories that most people
are already pretty familiar with. Other times,
though, they introduce brand new subjects to a
largely ignorant audience. So it goes in
Dumb: The Story of Big Brother Magazine.
Director Patrick O'Dell shines a
spotlight on this obscure publication,
which somehow catapulted a generation of skaters
to fame and also led to the creation of MTV's
Jackass. Featuring interviews with a number
of the era's icons, this movie tells the story
of a generation of young rebels who eventually
became incredibly successful within their fields.
Dumb isn't quite as widely known
as many of the films on this list,
but it's earned plenty of praise from critics,
who hailed the film as an effective chronicle of a
group of people who felt like breaking the rules…
for no other reason than because they could.
Although it wasn't as much of a phenomenon
as the original March of the Penguins,
this sequel features all of the elements
that make the first film so winning.
Morgan Freeman returns to narrate the project,
and the story at the film's center is just as
compelling as anything that happens in the first
film. The Next Step follows a group of penguins as
they journey to a mysterious destination after
one of their young hears an enigmatic call.
Above all else, this sequel, which came
more than a decade after the original film,
serves as proof that penguins make deeply
compelling subjects for nature documentaries. Of
course, even as the documentary wonders at their
beauty, it's hard not to see the impending threat
of climate change hanging over their heads. To
that end, March of the Penguins 2 isn't just about
the beauty of Antarctic wildlife — it's also a
harsh reminder that it may not be around forever.
Too Funny to Fail is both hilarious
and refreshingly low-stakes.
The documentary tells the story of The Dana
Carvey Show — specifically, all the ways in
which it failed to succeed, despite the many
talented people working behind the scenes.
Stephen Colbert, Steve Carell,
and, of course, Dana Carvey
all worked on the show, but that didn't keep it
from flaming out in truly stupendous fashion.
In spite of the show's untimely demise, this
documentary remains a fairly lighthearted look at
what went wrong, including candid interviews with
all of these now-famous men. As it turns out, The
Dana Carvey Show may have been ahead of its time,
and Too Funny to Fail demonstrates how well many
of the show's sketches still hold up. And although
its failure might have been kinda depressing
at the time, the story here is told with a wry
smile — and the ever-useful benefit of hindsight.
Most magic shows tend to opt for spectacle
over meaning. With In & of Itself, however,
magician Derek DelGaudio steers hard into the
world of storytelling. Mixing amazing tricks with
his own personal narrative, the show becomes an
experience that's both dazzling and deeply moving.
In & Of Itself is a filmed version of
DelGaudio's stage show of the same name,
but it beautifully translates the experience to
screen. DelGaudio performs several tricks over the
course of the show, and none of them lose any of
their intense impact through the process of being
filmed. But though the tricks may be astounding,
they're also pretty deep: DelGaudio's show is an
examination of how we see ourselves, and how that
self-perception helps to guide the decisions we
make. It's absolutely mesmerizing, and arguably
one of the best things on Hulu full stop.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.